okay four people joining this livestream
we are looking at functions that have
been considered experimental in earlier
versions of Wolfram language and we are
exploring what we can do to bring them
out of experimental status and make them
permanent commitments in the language
okay first section here is about
Geographics well I like to explain a
material graphics the only thing that
I'd like to comment there was some
feature that I was thinking was not
there the ability to switch to satellite
view yes and also the messaging excuse
me when you go to close in satellite
view where you know there is some mode I
mean we just can't have people have
closed satellite view with our you know
integrated services providers okay
without them subscribing to that I'm
making sense I mean we can deliver that
stuff we just can't deliver it you know
we can't have them generate millions of
tiles there right but I don't think
there's a problem I mean what's the
status of dynamic image
it's the I don't think anybody from that
is in this meeting
okay does anybody object to the
experimental icing dynamic Geographics
I'll just have one quick look at the
design when the design is basically the
same as Geographics okay and I can
resize this thing right it was pretty
nice we just have to get it integrated
into Wolfram Alpha now okay fine well
presumably that should be easier now
that we have the cloud version
absolutely and now that we have the new
containerization you know that the new
front-end pull of an alpha um okay
alright I think this is good alright um
would we go I'm good with this okay ROG
is there anything else for me nope okay
see what about the other ones in the
same family oh wow why is that not why
is that not experimental put them for
some reason
augmented doesn't point to snub it's
been snubbed the snub polyhedron has
been snubbed can somebody say why does
augmented not point to snub and why
would snob experimental in the first
place well when we I mean we went to the
hole full of those corporation on poor
yet one I think I just at the end that
you felt like snob was not the right one
for there was no precise ways on so you
say well let's just put it experimental
for the time being well let's talk about
it why
you know I hate this takes the same
options as we really have to get these
you know so you don't have to go look at
another page right for it what did I say
about snub polyhedron when we were first
looking at this what was my reason and
also can you explain the reason why old
meant it doesn't point to snub oh that's
why be taking my Xiaomi sticker sakes
okay fine all right but so explain to me
why I didn't like this do you remember
no not really
I guess maybe there was an example you
couldn't reproduce or such a team but
there was there were let's take a look
at this great picture so I mean the most
famous creature is the snub cube okay is
that right
that doesn't look right to me those look
at it not right it's so tight fully
drawn data of snob cube oh come on come
on
why does that not work anteater not
supported in graphics you should pop it
for your own property
laughs come on we can do this that that
seems like something we should make work
makes sense
okay what's the story here is anybody
going to respond I mean so that has no
idea
I mean smooth so let's make it work okay
what what is going on here come on
what's happening it's not chill visa not
ETV does support on well then you should
because it's got to actually
interoperate you can't just be adding
random new things to the system without
having them connect with other stuff but
we don't support on TT in all of our
systems that's the whole thing but we
should be supporting it wherever we can
and this is an example of a place where
we can and we should do it okay we will
do it I mean we did that for coffee it
you know it's takes some time and some
effort so real doing well I understand
but that's what we should have happen I
mean we okay now explain to me why this
snub cube right
see that's not cube see how regular it
is okay this is what was wrong this is
what happened last time right
explain to me why this snub cube is all
smooshed and irregular while this snub
cube is not right so what we essentially
return it's a topologically equivalent
fully adult so you can always change oh
yeah I understand that but this is doing
geometry so why is it that this snub
cube is not the same as this is not cube
so essentially the coordinate we pick
the coordinate in the base on this
internal path so a set of parameters
right so but we are sure that it's not
cube I took that topologically
equivalent we cannot guarantee that are
dramatically explained because clearly
in this case there is a set of
parameters which would make them
geometrically equivalent how are we
picking the parameters for snubbing we
pick a global one otherwise we need to
own an algorithm for every single one
which is unrealistic
okay okay who else is Roger here
who else can comment on this yeah just
I'm here okay so can you comment on this
this this seems wrong and this is I
remember now and I wish I wish we had
enough notes that from the previous
design review of why we experimental
eyes and that's something we should keep
in future you understand if we if if the
thing you know if there's a reason why
it was experimental eyes right like that
we couldn't resolve this do we have any
places for keeping that information I
think that should go into reference page
though if there's a comment like that we
should capture it on the reference page
otherwise I don't know where it would go
well I don't see a problem with that I
don't necessarily think it's appropriate
for users because it might be just we
ran out of time in this version and
things you know no no no but it
shouldn't be so it an excluded note but
says okay I think we should put in a
standard place on it on the source
source of the reference page otherwise
we'll never notice it in the discussion
like this mm-hmm
in other words we should have you know
so Roger I think that would be less
probably a good idea actually because
that gives us a more flowy yeah I mean
it means that in this meeting we're
capturing those you know exactly that
that section and ROG could automatically
harvest that for these meetings right as
long as it is in a certain cell context
yeah so so we need to create that cell
then yeah I think design discussion
would be a reasonable place to put it
you could just harvest usually that's
filled with all kinds of other things
okay fine fine well then okay then fine
um I mean it does seem right but it's
usually filled with all kinds of other
things okay well why don't we put it
because I think it could be a more
generic thing it's like future
discussion or something because it could
be something where when you come back to
review this function
it isn't experimental but there's still
something about it that wasn't finished
or should be extended so does usually
what's in there what's in we're in
design discussion yeah okay all right
well come up
the name for this but I would recommend
something which doesn't become vestigial
just because it got the experimental
iced so make sense yeah because and I
think it's worth well there's no problem
if we over harvest you know if we got
something that's experimental and it has
a future discussion then we harvest the
future discussion for the experiment the
experimental ization discussion all
right now explain so there's some
geometry you need to explain here okay
is it the case that when we all you need
to basically say you know your basic
listen you'd need to say so there is a
neighborhood information that tells you
what's nearby right gives you snubbing
corners you're truncating corners the
question is how much you're going to
truncate them so is it the case that
there is eight so if I make myself a
nice sum I'm by the way we cut some
background noise so somebody might want
to adjust something um so if I do this
okay so that's I don't stand by that
zero snubbing okay I see so there's some
snobbery wow that's really funky well
one additional thing with some of these
polyhedral operations when they work on
non convex things they don't you know it
I understand but this is a perfectly
happily convex creature so let me just
understand something in the case of
augmented polyhedron is there a similar
issue I don't think so it's unique isn't
it no I think it's a similar issue there
what I want to know okay so so the
question is how big do you want to
augment it oh yeah but there's no no but
there's no irregularity so here the
symmetry look here's the problem that
I'm having the symmetry of the cube is
preserved
in this augmentation right okay the
problem that I'm having here is in this
snubbing the symmetry of the cube is not
preserved right in the official snub
cube here the symmetry of the cube is
preserved if I'm not mistaken is is that
correct that the symmetry of the cube is
preserved in this snubbing what kind of
symmetry I mean rotational symmetry I
mean all the symmetry operations you
know the group of the cubes is also a
symmetry of the snub cube true or not
true I think it is so that's the problem
that I'm having with this with this
snubbing for some reason and I don't
really understand why snubbing is not so
why do so is that the case is just an
implementation issue we will fix I will
make sure to fine but I mean I'm trying
to understand why that's not hot so
another question with this parameter
when it's zero why isn't that just an
ordinary cube and by the way you haven't
documented the second argument of snub
by hydron which is wrong right yes but
um okay let me look at Augmented now for
a second okay so there you have said how
to augment it okay I am just confused
here help me out why is the zero case
not just a cube but nothing snubbed off
it's it's a book it's a corner case is a
bug we're going to fix but we do you
mean it's a corner case why is it not a
limit as R goes to zero because it the
way we actually compute it I mean the
region every dude there's no polyhedron
is a combination of a sequence of
operation they may happen that in that
corner case it doesn't work that's why I
don't understand this working for you
because I understand why isn't this a a
conceptually straightforward operation
you go to every corner and what what
does it mean
there's some strange lists on the
definition you go to every corner and
then what do you do you look at every
edge and you shorten every edge by some
fraction is that correct or is that not
correct
Joseph charlie dots does the way but
temperamental eaters cannot be the way
so that's because he just doesn't work
that way I mean to implement if you be
friendly slow you don't get dough right
okay so you need to do some more work on
this basically I mean as far as I'm
concerned if it if it and we should make
some comment about this well it's I mean
yeah it looks to me like it's just buggy
right now because it just shouldn't
break the symmetry just doesn't make any
sense for it to break the symmetry see
what I'm saying
sure if he's Dutch we just not a problem
because remember but I but why would you
ever even think it could make sense for
it to break the symmetry I'm very
confused
the somebody is making a lot of
background noise I don't know that is
but it really good if you put yourself
on mute no my my my key point is the
following is that when we define its
Nopalea tone for any arbitrary
polyhedron
there is no preservation of symmetry
involved this man is the beveling on the
truncation and those truncation and
beveling in principle 1/2 parameter who
doesn't allow you to always Davonte that
symmetry that you preserve the symmetry
so we implemented that general
operations we make me wish you know we
can make sure that when you manipulate a
cube cube in the description of the
operation yeah no I understand it but I
don't understand well actually I don't
stand in the case of the cube how any
length yes clearly you can change the
length right but I don't understand
ok so roughly there it seems roughly
symmetric now as you go further I just
don't understand
how it's losing its symmetry I don't
understand how I think there's a bug I
think there's a math mistake here yes on
that one ridiculous okay fine
why don't you explore this because I am
pretty certain that there has to be
something wrong that's causing it to
break the symmetry here so okay all
right let us return to this question
later okay on to the next item
um okay so here we have two functions
I've set my pan covering subset map is
starting to have its day in the Sun with
quantum computing which was the original
reason yeah I mean I am pretty happy
with subset map I I um
it seems like it's been pretty natural
do you agree yes I think this the design
of this function is clear modulo some
extensions of the third argument which
is also the second argument in the
curried form right what are those
extensions we have discussed other times
notations for Collins said that um okay
well I don't have a problem at the
experimental eyes in the sky and I think
it's named as is proved okay do you
agree I think so I haven't seen any
complaint in that regard I mean I sort
of can remember what it does based on
its name which is always good okay let's
go on curry so we had a thing recently
what was the function we were just
looking at that was last week we were
looking at ordering in relation to
Carlos are sending understanding of
orderings yes to have the basic form
here called reversed
and actually Roman has suggested
something similar so Romans point was
that Korea is doing simultaneously two
things the Carine of one argument
functions and the reordering of the
first two yeah so maybe we should get
rid of the reordering idea and put that
in this reversed function yes so he
suggests that the default case should be
equivalent of curry to not not curry
reversing the first two arguments
okay so curry - we do what let me look
at this for a second yep so carry two is
taking one argument at a time but in the
same order a curry of s comma - right
what the default curry s will reverse I
don't understand why the default is not
something I mean it's kind of useless
but I mean the curry one would just do
this right little it's a it's no op
right so the curry - so it's taking the
arguments in the same order if we don't
have the second argument of curry if
it's just curry F it will reverse the
order and our our argument few months
ago was that that's the most frequent
case in our operator forms yeah does
this work
well it's good to be waiting there for
an infinite number of Parliament so
effectively it doesn't work but we'll
just do well we just merge the arguments
so the idea of curries that doesn't
matter how you pass the arguments in any
group of Parliament it's there just
waiting for the right number of
arguments by the way um Ethan our live
stream is commenting on polyhedra and
complaining that we don't support
refraction and shadows and reflections
we don't we have a project to do I mean
more advanced shader type stuff maybe
the group of people here is wrong maybe
Roger can comment on that and there's no
active project right now there's been
discussions going back for a long time
we will do shaders we'll do quite a bit
of shaders in 12-1 not yet covering
shadows and things like that but it's
funny I mean back in the early 1990s we
were going to do that and it just turned
out people didn't care enough um yeah I
think that well
get on a side note here but even there
now - da Vinci live soft shadows we can
hardly do that today
mmm so if it's it's there's no current
project but will will you know it's I
think that as we get warmed up in doing
more shader work I think shadows what is
the best path for somebody who actually
wants to do that so they create all the
stuff with our nice new polyhedron
things and then they want to do a retro
realistic rendering what's the best path
these days for exporting - what - Maya -
something else what what do you explore
- it depends on I mean you can just
export to pop rain you can export - I
don't know that Maya - shadows either
other I'm just curious other other like
free product that like do shadows and
things that I say and do we ha
interesting do we have a workflow
describing how to do that I mean do we
have an export to render man what is the
random and format what we have if we
supported that a while ago I think oh
yeah well
to remember with shadows it's like
transparency it's a global operation so
it's obviously very complicated right
yeah games are clearly very interested
in doing that but they of course have
performance
constraints today approximately it is
like an endless set of methods how to
get decent shadows and still be
performant right it would be nice if we
gave a workflow if we had a workflow
that we could reference on these pages
that told people how to go from our
graphics to something that is fully for
a realistic using some you know easily
available external system if we know if
we know the answer to how to do it we
should go to workflow that says it does
that make sense
sure Charles can can is that something
you can I mean so probably somebody in
our art department knows you know if if
nobody else knows knows a reasonable way
to do this okay um okay a couple of
comments on the live stream here that
are interesting Ethan is saying subset
Maps should work on numeric arrays
without having to decompress them
interesting comment who would like to
does it work on packed arrays internally
yes and bucket array does numeric array
I guess it's been spending throughout
the system
we'll get there okay um
sandir comments that the wiki article
about snub cubes talks about it being a
chiral polyhedron with two distinct
forms which are enantiomorph serve each
other
okay so there's clearly a complicated
story here I think this is a Charles
gets to invest
what's going on here well actually if
you twice Nopalea Don of the health
wanted there is a third argument which
we didn't want to document we'll give
you the symmetry in just the whole good
so okay so it's the well you didn't even
document the second argument so I don't
know what any what what any of these
things do so you're saying most of them
have fraction and so you could imagine
that you specify both beveling and the
truncating so okay so the second one is
some truncation thing okay so there
exists a Wow okay so somewhere in this
space
there's the symmetric all right this
requires more math thinking okay let's
come back to the let's see we were we
were talking about curry right yes and
now we have four among with us okay no I
yes
we're discussing the default of curry
and I was saying that you were
suggesting Roman to have the default
ordering here yeah basically we won two
rather than two one okay how serious are
we about reversed well I think that's
going to be useful for some cases like
the order situation we were discussing
with Carlos the other day the other
thing that Rama has pointed out is that
is whether we want this function to be
carried as well so the design we were
thinking for reversed was that it would
take always two brackets and the second
one is any number of arguments and it
would reverse all of them
yeah I understand but if we want to
carry it so that it takes one argument
at a time as well then we can only do
that force two arguments the alternative
is to do carry of reversed of F which
would be the operator form right which
the current career of F with the current
default gifts which I don't think is
very obvious as a default no it's not I
mean I I do think that reversed is a
better idea yes I mean carry is useful
and operator forms are useful but we
shouldn't call it carry if it's not well
I don't think we want either to force
users to use combinations of Kaveri and
reversed continuously okay let's look at
okay let me understand the situation
here okay so the first question is
reversed
um so remind me again you know what
we're doing here you know we could have
something do you have the implementation
of of us could you please you just serve
it to its one-liner um yes I mean that
would then would work right all right um
is there any assumed withholding with
reversed you know I mean clearly if you
have a hold all function it's not clear
that the reversed function should in a
perfect world inherit that hold holding
does holding with corridas holding work
no whiskery we cannot propagate their
dam yeah but I bet we could with
reversed if we didn't curry it
and that might be quite useful with
things like set okay so the issue is
what if we wanted to have a curried form
of this thing here right and so what
you're saying is boy okay okay thank you
um yes curry of reversed of F that is
the thing that will build these operator
forms where it swallows the second
argument and freezes it that is a very
simple implementation okay so so then
this becomes this right we're all happy
there right this becomes this okay so
now you're saying curry are reversed of
F and now that curry if we defaulted the
curry to be the comma to curry there
then that would be then we will get
career back f of XY there nope that's
not what I want anyway that's not that's
not the curry cost this is what I of X
yes yes that built our or pointer forms
right and and if I were to do this then
that will do that and if I were to do
curry comma three that does that which
is right
do you think reversed is gonna need an
arbitrary permutation I don't think so I
think the complicated cases should be
handled by curry
if need it because it has a permutation
on it right I I do think we need the
permutation in curry because there are
some operator forms like my bot which is
rather complicated yes because it
carries the first and the third argument
and so users may want to curry
complicated things with
all right listen let's do the following
let's get reversed in the system and
make sure that that shakes down and lets
clan tentatively 2d document well the
question is whether we change curry of F
when we change curry of F I would
suggest curry of F should do what
everybody expected scary of F to do
which is a single level curry of X of Y
oh yes
yes so the default argument second
argument should be to so explain that to
me I mean when I think of Korean I think
of it going all the way not just two
levels what what is all the way I mean
the problem is suit our functions you
don't see how many arguments they have I
mean in the theoretical the way curry
was developed it was always in typed
languages where you always knew how many
arguments a function would take and that
would always be fixed number of
arguments and so because our functions
can have any number of arguments we need
that second argument of curry to tell it
how many to swallow I just wonder if
there's a default that can depend on
earth you know it's a system function
you might be able to know it's kind of
hokey I mean many functions even have
optional arguments and sure so by just
to me that curry you know taking the it
to be to by default just seems very
arbitrary I mean it is there a more
obvious as it is there a more you know
to me swallowing everything would make
more sense for the default than
swallowing too well-defined you know how
many person brackets are coming later
when you are looking at the first one so
what don't you get isn't this a sub
value thing
yes but the head will evaluate before
the whole expression so there's a value
with the first pair of brackets will
fire before before having the
opportunity of looking at other terms or
brackets I mean it will never be able to
evaluate because it is always one more
to come what why is there was one more I
mean why isn't it I don't understand if
this that doesn't the tree this is a sub
tree right this is a sub tree of a
certain shape and you are ascending out
of that sub tree after you finish the
you know finish with the sub bracketing
z' if I'm not mistaken in other words if
I were to say look if I would take this
and
I were to say G of that comma you or
something that is a different subtree
yes but the head carry F 2x is going to
evaluate on its own before anything else
in Y and C why why is it kind of
evaluate before anything else because
that's how the evaluator works I mean
doing what you suggest would require a
change in the evaluator it's not
implementable as it is right now okay
let me understand that but I mean to me
what I'm suggesting makes the most sense
for career one argument to mean see what
I'm saying
it's the most natural thing for it to
mean there is a subtree there is a left
subtree and this says you know basically
excavate the whole left subtree but the
main use of curry is to have incomplete
versions so you you would say something
like G equals curry of F comma 2 of X
but then G you applied the Y would fire
but not on its own I I understand I
understand that's all good but then
you're giving that explicit to what I'm
addressing is what is the default when
the two is missing and your point is
that whatever I apply F would never get
out of it okay so your question is when
does it fire how does it know it's
complete right because in an expression
it will try to evaluate the head first
which is itself an expression with
brackets and so it will valuate that
before evaluating the result on the pair
of brackets under Indonesian pair of
brackets
so we would have to tell somehow the
evaluator we are in a special situation
so don't do the standard thing well I
mean the other thing we could obviously
have which is a completely different
kind of thing as a terminator but you
could say if you ever are fed this then
you want to digest it tight type thing
you get what I'm saying so in other
words if instead of Z you were fed
terminate a terminator there I'm sure
there's some place where people have
used combinators and they've they've you
know built whole giant you know zoos of
weird Combinator animals accommodated
yes but there's never an ambiguity of
the number of arguments before all the
fires
because any given Combinator has a fixed
number of arguments is that right but it
has a certain number of patterns that
simplify and these patterns do not have
doubled length so stuff like that and
right I mean you could say yes I mean
for example s only fires if it has at
least three arguments and K fires and it
is two and so there is never please
never know I understand that okay so
listen here's what I'm thinking I'm
thinking we should de document the one
argument form of curry and basically how
it not evaluate because I don't think we
know what it should do
I think this two thing is really
arbitrary I mean I are quite I mean they
are the majority of of stuff like is but
it's two argument functions I mean holy
all the arithmetic all the mathematics
the previous case was more natural
because in most of our operator forms we
switch will be the first one mentss yeah
yeah yeah when would we use the curry
the unfledged curry we have a few cases
like Matt or apply so it's conceivable
that users have similar functions but
but it's less frequent okay so the
flipped car a is now achieved how by
reversed which which chooses to curry is
that right right
how can reversed curry and not have run
into the same issue about not knowing
how many arguments it's got to have
because you're saying reversed of F by
default eats what what does it eat what
we can make reversed to carry just one
thing we can not make it curry me I mean
we have to with reversed we have two
main choices either we make the second
argument take many arguments
or we make make it curvy arguments like
curry I prefer the first case I think
it's going to be more user stories
filled again the first case yeah the
first case is like reversed of what a
problem there that the second argument
take any number of arguments um sorry
say that again I'm sorry I was so so
there in the implementation in this one
liner they're reversed of F it takes any
number of arguments in the second pair
of brackets that's fine but so what's
your current proposal your proposal is
that if it if it has that you have an
additional form which says reversed
bracket X bracket Y so doesn't know I
think that's odds one blank blank comma
args - yes but x1 would be only one x2
why is it only one what why because we
want to this thing distinguish from the
first case the first case should have
should fire only when arcs is - autumn
or at least yeah I get it
exactly so I think we shouldn't try to
implement both because it would be a
mess but we have these two options do we
go with the first type of thing or the
second type of thing you wrote I think
we should definitely support the first
thing the first one yeah I do before the
first one right I think this is again
mixing the roles of Korean reversed
right exactly okay so then then in order
to get the functionality that we
currently have for curry of F what would
we have to do even think it has to be
curry of reverse stuff s why are we
putting ourselves through this why high
19 yes yeah why don't we just leave it
the way it is I mean in other words
that's kind of
you'll write that the curry reversing
the reversing courier is a little weird
but it is the more useful thing than a
pure curry of two isn't it yeah but it
shouldn't be called curry I mean it's
our goodness sake once once we have a
permutation in the second argument I
think having a permutation as default is
not so bad and it's it's like a
transpose for example yeah which has 2 1
as its default permutation I mean the
point Roman is that as you're saying I
mean so given that we have a permuting
curry if you can come up with another
name for curry please suggest it we
spent like an hour just talking about
that one name and eventually we decided
that every name we could come up with
was more obscure than just saying curry
yes I mean we could go back to our
standard way of naming things and
there's a spider person who invented
them and in fact the one we are looking
at the curry that commutes the arguments
is called Curry's C the C Combinator
which was also described by curry said
be curly C would be the kind of
non-obvious
okay I'm only gonna do Shawn Fink alas
[Laughter]
we should but I mean we cannot use ice
and K by themselves right but with a
package where they're called Combinator
has accommodated K yeah that that's but
I mean everywhere else we actually use
the name of the people who who described
them so why we shouldn't do the same
here well but I understand that no
that's completely obscure so for example
I faintly knew that this was that there
was a curry that there was a C
Combinator but only faintly and I'm you
know I'm a pretty serious Combinator
enthusiast as Combinator enthusiastic oh
um I don't buy that argument I don't buy
the argument that that I mean to me the
fact that our default curry is a
curry of F comma - really useful as a
default I mean it for example if I need
to manufacture a function that adds one
to its argument I would say 1 + 1 equals
curly of + comma 2 of 1 I mean for me
carrot forms most beautiful but if they
are not yet complete I agree that's fine
but notice that you're happily putting
that 2 in there well now I have to yes
of course I mean I agree that 2 is a bit
arbitrary but then maybe it's better to
not ever a default second argument yeah
but but the point is that this operation
of flipping mm-hm
you know is clearly useful particularly
in our language we use it you know we
use it a bunch III personally I'm not
I'm not horrified no after this
discussion given that I don't think we
should curry reversed I think it's a
mistake to curry reversed
I think reversed is just a you know
essentially a functional operator form
that does not also have currying
um I mean I don't know why by the way
the only reason that we don't have
Combinator s Combinator K and so on I
mean we obviously they're totally
trivial to put in there and I I think
the reason that we don't have them is we
had a whole issue about right what we
wanted to do was to let people be able
to type Combinator strings just like
they can type you know where so that I
can type you know something quotes K s k
KS you know whatever it is right yes but
I mean if you're serious about that we
would need a left associative finally
operator without any meaning right to me
just but there with a nice symbol nobody
I mean but this if I'm not mistaken I
mean yes no I know that I know that I
know that but we could say what we did
was you know Combinator um you know if
we did something like Combinator of this
turns into Combinator K of s of whatever
it is right I mean with our wide
associative brackets it just doesn't
look very nice I mean don't we have
assembly we could use as a as a leftist
active they loved associative binary
support isn't an experiment isn't at
Star no that's composition right that's
not to so you want something okay so the
issue I was literally just writing about
this in this weird detective story about
this note in this Turing book about the
left associativity convention which I
hadn't really internalized properly but
Tim it would have to be binary so it
would have it would it would apply it
couldn't be flat I know obviously that
was one but as I recall so let me look
at a random Combinator expression think
I had some big long Combinator
expressions someplace here um okay now
that has brackets in it yeah I mean it's
just unreadable
right B you're saying that this can be
bracket less if you do last
associativity is that coming you you
will still use parentheses for grouping
but a lot less then you need those
brackets I wish this why doesn't that do
[Music]
well there's a good unreadable one okay
so what are you saying you're saying I
have this which is arguably a mess and
you're saying if I were to use a left
associative operator mm-hmm why why does
that give me fewer so wait a minute what
how can I use just parentheses with a
left associative operator do we have
okay we have a lot of operators that
don't mean anything do we have any of
them being left associative I mean I'm
just amazed here this doesn't come up
because we we um okay so something like
circle dot um is is it flat it does
appear to be flat but yours
that of all of these things of all of
these operations we don't have any left
associated one it seems very hard to
believe yeah I mean we and we have is we
have plenty of characters available
right we should use it a nice moment and
just put in the passing rules that's
really all that is required
passing formatting it well why don't you
take it upon yourself to pick an
operator isn't doesn't already have some
meaning I mean it would be good you know
I was looking at this thing of Turing's
where he has some just I mean it wasn't
helped by the typesetting that was done
but it absolutely truly atrocious
notation where he's got things that look
like primes meaning a pre operator um I
mean it needs to be some kind of dot
like thing I was yes yes and not but not
confused with any dot that has a meaning
right well I mean clearly one thing if
it was a semicircle pointed in which
direction if it was a if this if the way
it looked was a I mean does this make
any sense so if it's a left associative
operator that means that s dot a dot B
dot C is equivalent to a dot B yes dot C
right yes and so is there a way if you
wouldn't write that operator as
something which has a certain binding I
mean the convention is to leave out
these parentheses so and you would only
put parentheses if you if we wanted
something like a dot parent is a speed
on C and that's why you have a lot fewer
of these I don't understand why that
gives you fewer I don't see what isn't a
symmetrical problem no no I mean it the
way they are built up is that they're
mostly you see the whole the whole
initial segment there is left there so
[ __ ] if so did the all those brackets
would simply go away
so okay so what you're saying here is
that if I were to take I mean that there
is a a way of doing what is it cool it's
called infix right um there's a so this
thing here has application has function
application how would I rewrite this so
this is this allows left associative
okay so if I say in fix of let's say
just F of a B C comma let's say a
hundred comma left oh it's not doing
that that's I see you know what I want
to do is F of H oh okay so then this one
so you're saying I go head there okay no
precedents grouping yes but the X bar
has to be flat ties you okay so you're
saying this and I'm confused
no this is no no this would be something
like that
what is going on let's try the basic
example here okay I'm a fish
confused why are those things not
working restaurants and grouping doesn't
appear to work how pretty say for you
stoves well okay
look Roman could you take it upon us I'm
trying to unscramble this and you can
take this very example and and show what
it looks like in case where you're using
okay come on Amy that notebook please
yeah Bob mailer this Combinator but also
the in fixed stuff below can we do this
with item parenthesis only it's in at
enough well what does that okay hold on
hold on let me look at something here
you're saying a at be at sea yes and
perhaps we have that in parentheses and
then add something else
why does that need to be in parentheses
because saying sometimes we need to take
these as a whole function applied to
something else
exactly and you're saying that's the
left associative that that forces
I'm so confused here well it's that
associative or that is there's no
associate no I'm very good this is not
about associativity it's just a notation
which implements well it is about
associativity because because a at be at
C Associates computes B of see it's
right associative it computes be at see
before it does a at that is what I'm
saying I saw it it's right associative
it it goes look a at B at C is
equivalent to a at be at C right which
is not equivalent to a at B at sea right
right we are out of time but but I just
like to take a look okay so Roman could
you take a look at this and and I do
think we should finally introduce these
Combinator's and I I think you know
named Combinator's are a fine thing to
have okay this is gonna be a more
complicated discussion oh boy are you
confident
all persistent structure is working yeah
I'm confidence about persistence I still
have some reservations about the
initialization so I'm probably
overconfident there I mean the thing
works but I mean we still need a few
auxiliary support stuff like browsers
for initializations because it's very
bad if you have one an initialization
persistent stuff that you don't know
about and that gets in the way and so
persistence is okay initialization we're
going to have to come back to this in
different meeting but but I just want to
comment for Christians benefit since
he's been patiently waiting here I would
like to consider making web image search
default the thumbnails okay I don't know
people think well every time I use it I
end up using thumbnails yeah I did the
same thing um and it's a little weird to
have it yeah I don't know people think
about this I agree that these could be
the experimental eyes unless the only
thing about screen image is this
question about which screen you're
talking about but I guess we're okay
with that I guess that works okay
this needs more discussion wow you don't
want to do experimental eyes external
evaluate okay all right listen III need
to go here we've got more to figure out
I think we caught some useful things
here ah a lot of work a lot of work um
okay any lost coins from anybody
nope okay thanks everybody here thanks
to folks on the livestream appreciate it
see you later